[Music]
Welcome Nice to see you all I'm Inge van
de Ende I'm A data Scientist at Dexter
Energy we forecast renewable Energy
Production and Today I'm gna talk about
conformal prediction And especially how
you can apply it to calibrate
probabilistic  Time series forecast so in
the talk earlier Today It Was like Who
did ever attend
Time Ser Presentation data This is the
second One we
Today start
in I will start with talking about how
it Can Help Us to accelerate renewable
Energy
Trans renewable Energy for example wind
turbine delivers The Energy to the
electricity gd electricity Grid Always
needs to be Balance
of
time
ex
Cheng
Time
wind
wind how much wind is there gna be
tomorrow exactly at that Second Of The
Day I don't know I Can Only forecast it
and the  percentage of Wind and Solar
Energy in the grd is increasing the grd
get more and more dependent on this
uncertainty the solution that is to
predict that uncertainty explicit It
can very much help in Decision making
because It will be very Different If You
know that You'  re quite certain or that
If You're very uncertain If You're very
uncertain you probably have to take More
measures to prepare to Balance The Grid
and if you predict this uncertainty you
can do it in Different properties of the
Energy market so we can  do it when we
forecast Supply So What I talked about
If You forecast the Wind or If You
forecast Solar you can also do the same
Thing for Demand because Demand Always
is a bit uncertain and you can do the
same Thing If You forecast The price
Because  The price combines The
Production and the Demand into One So
also that uncertainty
procrastinator and now Dive into a
little bit more of the technical details
for you so Common Point forecast metrics
Don't really Give Us Any information
about this uncertainty so here you see
uh  A Time series forecast with on the
horizontal Axis the time so t Zero Is
Now so we Use the data Until now to
forecast Into The Future And On The
Vertical exit It can be Any property So
What I talked about Before
Demand Demand Production or Price but
you can also Keep Your Own case in mind
Maybe You're working on a forecast that
You're making right now keep that in
mind because what I'm going to talk about
It's Not Only applicable to the Energy
market but you can use it for  Any model
that you have That's The nice Thing
actually About This Method so we have a
point forecast but how certain is it we
have no clue the only thing is that We
Know It's Not gna Be Perfect so Never
actually gna be correct so One Method to
add some information about it is to add
prediction interval inad of One Point
add two More Points to
of values ​​to R indicate
Little very
unc know I
to make my
Decision
have the correct coverage coverage If
talk about the amount ofs actually The
interval that
Give Method  that can do that Us that
will Give Us correct coverage is
prediction I
to Thing Method is
mod use Any forec mod
that Any working on can Just Keep using
the same model that you right now
exactly As it
is Just add extra
information that it also has  the
statistical guarantee that will the
correct coverage
there how can we do that
it
Do
ction we train set calibration set and
test Set the calibration set is G Give
Us more information
cty We will do that in steps we start
with training
calibration prediction I will go  through
Them
One
training can use Any Point forecast
model so Here
ehm You just train your model how you
always do using your training Set it Can
Be regression It can be three based but
also Deep Learning Any model you have so
That's quite Easy step now we  go to the
calibration so now you predict with your
model for the calibration set and you're
going to Look at the residual so the
difference between The Actual values
that you have in your calibration set
and the prediction That You Made
in conform prediction Those reside are
called conformity
scores here in the Slide IND as Arrow the
difference between your Actual
value prediction for that specific
Moment In
Time You create Sorted list of the
absolute conformity scores And then you
can Select The specific Quant that
interested in and I also this Slide a
little  bit more
how it resembles in
Python so the same Thing Again But Now I
gave It some name so Here have three
errors the biggest One is Number One and
the smallest one is number three I
actually create The list It's just an
array with the absolute value  starting
with the biggest One and I can Select
The quanta that I'm interested In so for
example If I talk about that It's The 90
interval or It's The 40 interval depends
On The Question you w answer what kind
of interval
Look at eh and you
selected value so here you have your
confidence level you do that One minus
your confidence level Times The length
of the list And then we're in Python so
Do minus One Because We start counting
at Zero And then we have the index that
you w to  Select in it list so It's
actually Pretty Easy equation And that
value you need to Keep when you make
your
prediction so then we go to the last
step
we predict Our Point forecast model so
Again this is not Different For Anything
Else that you would already have  done
And then we Just add The prediction
interval On Top of it
so The width of the prediction interval
We Found that in the calibration step
Just A set Wi You just add It Around The
forecast that you have So You Sum It or
subtract it you can  see in the graph as
well that It's constantly over the test
set that I'm predicting for So if I'm
forecasting for example for one day It
will be constant over that full
Day so small recap you train your Point
forecast model you use the  calibration
set to look what actually happens in the
Actual values ​​in the calibration set and
based on that you can Add a prediction
interval About Your
forecast Now talk about Python we're
here at P data There is nice packages
that you can use for this it  make it
very easy to do this so I think the most
used package is Maybe It's really Early
package that was developed it's very
extensive and a bit newer package that I
Personally like a lot is craps eh Why
It's I find it a little bit more user
Friendly especially If You w to Dive
Into the code and read What actually
happens but that's a personal preference
you can use
how do
pth not that Big of differ inad of my
normal baseline model The Basel model
would that forec model
could mod regr model model
using
w
Do prop because It Doesn't contain The
calibration set so It's Only the
training part you calibrate it so then
you have One extra step and you can
predict Both your value and the interval
Around it so you have in the point
prediction It Will Be  One One array with
one value per sample that You're
predicting And then in
the interval It will be two so the top
One and the lower One here you can also
see
If
prediction forec constant prediction
interval It act values ​​will
Somewhere This Is actually quite  A
Simple Method That makes It nice to use
especially Because you can Almost always
use
it so Always a good Start It has a lot
of advantages I already mentioned quite it
doing on the mod
Static guarantee the cover is be correct
Which is not the case for  most other
methods and you don't need to make Any
assumptions on Any distribution don't
need to say like it's Gaus uses The
distribution of the
date There's also disadvantages I will
Dive into bit more on the next
SL It's constantly over the prediction set
So
You quite Little information In Between
The Points and also prediction interval
doesn't provide You The information that
the full distribution Would Do
actually so The First One constantly over
the prediction set You're probably Not
forecasting One Point At that moment but
multiple Points  Maybe in my case It
Would Be Every minutes Of A Day and in
General in machine learnings Lot of data
All data Points of the Day and I know
that this One Point is G be very The
Other Point because That's How I Make my
forecast so actually  would like to use
that as well because Maybe One Point
Would Be More certain Than other Point
as well and now not using All That
information that I'm
having and Next The prediction
interval Less information probis
distribution So It Only gives you three
Points and actually  so Here on the left
I Just added the interval over Time if
you would Take Like A slice of that and
you would draw The distribution The
interval Would Be three Points but the
Actual distribution can Still have Any
Shape Within and can also have very
Different Shapes  for the same interval
So I'm still missing some information
that I Might need to make the correct
Decision based on this eh
also repat
many also of distribution Better methods
i in
moment That are the disadvantages
next part of the Presentation I Talk
other solution that  solves exactly
advantages
part ied How prediction to a prediction
interval So You Go from a model that
doesn't Give You Any information about
uncertainty to something that does Give
You information about that in the second
part of this Presentation I'm gna talk
about Calibra  A probabilistic uh
forecast So you already have a
probabilistic forecast you already know
something about the uncertainty but
we're going to Make sure It's
correct and to do that with conformal
prediction is very similar As the prev
part I explained we're gna do the same
Three Steps Again In Every step I gna
Explain What's the
difference so Let's start with training
so the same Thing as in the previous
part you can use Any model the only
difference Is It has to be a
probabilistic model So It has to give
you information about  More Than Just A
Point forecast It has to give you
preference the whole distribution so then
You're Talking More about Quantum
regression about the Quantum regression
Force also Some Kind of lms that do that
for you so That's your starting This is
a bit more specific  cases that you would
talk
about and Something to keep in mind is
that this distribution Here Just draw
One l You Could Kind of divide It Into
prediction intervals You Could say that
This is
% 40
to Name It intervals is we Use To
calibrate Question working probis  Time
Ser
for
regr that don't work with it I wan take
a little moment to step A Little Bit out
of the conformal prediction only and
Talk About Quantum regression so That
You also Have A model in mind that Would
Be The starting Point to do  this eh If
Quantum regression The Reason that I
picked that One is because it's the most
used then It's called conformal Quantum
regression So if you wan to Google It
that's a good term to start
with so Quantum regression What do you
do you wan to have not  Just the point
forecast but the full distribution so
what we do is we train One model for
Every Quant So if you can decide How
many quants you want to look at but if I
want to look at Every percentage for
example I'm gna train 99  Models for
percentage one two up 98 99 and all
those Models gna Give me a value If I
put Them Next To each other I have the
distribution eh and a very nice Thing
about it is because you train your model
constantly over Time ads
in If We  99 Models how are we make that
not all of Models me exactly the
prediction
in training I'm make predictions compare
To Act values ​​Of train
I'm to High The we to low I end up in
the best
estimation
asymetric The errors on One Side  I will
Count More heavily Than On The Other
Side So if It's Too low I will Count It
More heavily for example than When It's
Too High So if the values ​​That are to
the errors That are too low you Count
Them More heavily your model will become
a bit careful There and starts Moving to
the lower Side so here for 20 per you
will clearly see that the left side will
be steeper if you would do this plot for
1 per It Would Be even More asymmetrical
and the same holds for The Higher qu  Just
the other Way Around The Higher part is
Deeper this los function is Pin The
Reason that Pin is because Looks Like
the jump that is Made on pin machine you
can keep that in mind the term pin
machine the B
going end up
pin
So This Is  gna Give Us
The probability distribution so the
Pinball for 20 will be used in one model
P 80 in the other model and Those are
gna forecast Something differently and
Something very nice About It is that in
Python It's super easy so we work quite
a bit with  gbm If gbm model you only add
objective is Quant
The qu that w do and you don't to worry
About It anymore Just pred that
qu If distribution to do
multiple so I see Little B wondering
like Why Talking prediction qur Is
Awesome It adts To  My input
Spil
distribution
i
I
prediction eh a big difference is that
if you use conformal prediction or
conformal Quantum regression you have
the statistical guarantee of valid
coverage So It really uses The
distribution of your calibration set and
it matches that on Average your
prediction is correct  So You know that
on Average The prediction will be
exactly the distribution of your dat set
w for machine Learning Models the
asymptotic consistent so They Go towards
the
correct so in a world where you would
have the perfect feature Space And
Everything from reality is included in
All Of Your data you will have the
perfect quanta but Yes Who has That Ever
eh Cleaning up data is still interesting
topic as well so uh if you have a bit
more of an
underestimate of
distribution prediction regardless of
your input features can be super simple
model  that using as a starting Point You
know that on Average G be
correct then The Other Way Quantum regr
also advantages compare toal prediction
because very effective to adts To All
the information that you have about
specific sample Where eh The Basic
application of conformal prediction
doesn'  t do it and also There Is methods
for it but actually Quantum regression
is Just A Very Practical and effective
Way so it's not Without Reason that Big
part of the world is using conformal
Quant regression because conformal
Quantum regression really combines The
Best Of Both you use  the e practical
advantages of Quantum regr Still that
statistical
guarantee now we're gna
calibrate and now we're gna Do It per
interval of the probabilistic prediction
so Last Time we Did It Only Once now
we're gna Repeat it for Every prediction
interval  That We already Made With Our
model instead of comp comparing to One
Line we G compare to
interal we Inter 70 40 ofs is that
interval we list All Of The reside All
The differences between act value the
closest Line of the interval as
conformity SC Time not  absolute
values
[Music]
correction
Factor
for forec
Weis forecast as second step we add The
correction Factor that will either Make
The distribution wider More Nar we do
that Every qu
we
calibris forecast instead of Just
probis
calibrate on calibration
set prediction apply correction
Factor Now actually  all the
disadvantages that I took Before became
advantages Because We Still have Those
nice Things We Still doesn't rely on the
model you choose you have the
statistical guarantee you No
distribution assumptions
Before en eh It varies over over your
test set or prediction
set en  It gives you a full distribution
So It Looks Almost Too Good To Be True I
have to say There Was One disadvantage
That I didn't mention yet So Far so we
also have an assumption of Exchange
Ability so we don't do assumptions on
the  distribution of the data but there
is an assumption That's quite important
and That's The assumption that your data
is Exchange so that
eh You Could move Them Around over time
and for time series That's Not Always
the case So You Can have a data Drift so
Here I  gave an example where you clearly
see that the beginning of the time
series seems to have a Different pattern
than The End So It Doesn't really Hold
that you can Just freely uh randomly
Select your calibration set and freely
use that to give The distributions There
are also Solutions for that ehm
and Solutions actually Focus More on the
last part of the time series that you
have in your dataset add More we to that
but I have to say that if apply it you
lose the statistical guarantee and It
Gets
asymmetric
consistent It's
Trade interested in that Dive into It
More Look at the May Time series regress
you find a lot of information Good
starting
zo three
learnings About conformal prediction
That We had Today First It has the
statistical guarantee Something We're
not used to with having in our  machine
Learning Models and super nice to
actually have
that because you're certain that
Independent on your features It's gna BE
ON Average correct then you can make it
conditional very Easily If You apply
conformal Quantum regression and lastly
it Can Help to accelerate the renewable
Energy  transition but I really Believe
It can also help to accelerate a lot of
other topics as
well
and I'm Not The Only One talking about
this topic because it's really topic
That's Rising in Interest you can see
Here that At The Start Of
2002 starts of  2022 People Started
googling It clearly More so that makes
this topic very interesting to Keep
Following because it's Still In
development It Gets more more
attention new updates are coming All The
Time if you would like to do that and
you like to Follow this topic you can  go
to this repository and gives you a lot
of information It's really extensive So It
gives you a lot and Lot of information
and will also Give You new updates on
this topic and you can also see that
this repository in the G Stars It
Started In The  Start Of
2022 I don't It's a coincidence that h
It starts at the same moment It's a good
place to get your
information so that was My Presentation
Thank You Very Much coming and if you
like the topic and you actually Wan
apply it in a  notebook we're gna also
have a workshop in January so It's gna
be about the same topic but we have more
time actually gna Do It ourselves in
Python Thank you very
much
Ok thank you we have time for a couple
questions I Have A Question regarding
The Quantum regression did you encounter
Crossing cones and if you did How did
you go about that yeah yes we have that
eh yes you can either Inter Interpol It
or you can Just Switch Them Around That
are the things we use quite Simple but
for us
are  nicely in
l Yes we what we actually eventually did
was switching Them Around then we tred
to
also Take the Average Of The
values ​​Always increases takes The
Average of
points
Yes com a
problem Thank You Very Much I would like
to ask If this Method can work  also for
multi input multi
output Time Serious model Yeah
interesting I Would Say It Would work
but I haven't used It
eh yes I Would assume that you can apply
the same Thing
You don't have in your training data the
time series that you  want to
predict extra
features of
eh yes So You train The Target is Still
the same Time series as you w to predict
but you have extra input features Yes Okay
Yeah so then The conformal Quantum
regression is super nice because then
you actually use Those extra input
features in the first part of the
Presentation you would Still use Those
features to make the point forec but the
prediction interval Would Be totally
Independent of
them
Thanks for the Cool Talk First of all eh
The thing you mention at the end with
the data Exchange
Ability  Can I think of that as as the
same Thing as station of the time series
or is it More strict there is no
seasonal Possible or
Eh no I Would say it's not stationary
Yes yes is
ction How because random samp then to
Let's Create gaps In The  Time series or
If You Take the latest data You also
create lag in the training of your
model Yes the most general approach is to
just take random sample so Indeed you have
gaps you can also Sometimes even reuse
it in the train set and the calibration
set
eh on general You just take your train
set You Take Parts Out Of It and then
you use that in your calibration set And
then in the last part where I talked
about focusing More on the recent ones
you have to we
More ok Thank you I Is  All the time we
asked thank you so
[Applause]
[Music]
much
from